- [Kelly] But it's fine.
- [Michael] Can I ask a question
to both of you, just quick,
I know you're going to
cut me out of this, but
(Randy and Kelly laughs)
I love TV themes, what is your favorite,
you and you, what is your,
if you had to pick one television theme,
wham, what is it?
- [Kelly] Oh my god there's
- [Michael] Is that too hard?
- [Kelly] so many good
ones in like the '80s.
- [Randy] There's so many great ones, man.
- [Kelly] And the '90s.
- [Michael] I think I know
mine. I think mine's...
- [Kelly] Wait, what's yours?
- [Michael] Mine's Cheers.
♪ Making your way in the world today. ♪
- [Kelly] Okay, "Everybody
Knows your Name"
- [Michael] I love that song.
- [Kelly] Yeah. That's a good one.
- [Randy] I like ♪dun-dun,
dun-dun dun-dun-dun.
(group sings)
- [Michael] I Dream of Genie!
- [Randy] I Dream of Genie,
'cause I like the whole
bosom vibe going on.
- [Michael] I like it too.
- [Randy] You know what I mean?
- [Kelly] There's so many
in my head right now,
but I think, what's the
♪ Milkman, the paper boy, the evening TV ♪
- [Michael] Oh yeah! -
[Randy] Oh yeah, yeah, yeah!
- [Michael] Full House.
- [Randy] Yeah. Yeah.
- [Kelly] I like that song.
- [Michael] Yeah, I like that one.
♪ Everywhere you look ♪
- [Michael] ♪ Everywhere,
there's a place. ♪
- [Kelly] There were so many!
- [Michael] I could just, I
might just record that now.
- [Kelly] ♪ Step by step, ♪
- [Randy] You should record that.
- [Kelly] ♪day by day, ♪
- [Randy] Wait a minute. A duet. tonight.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Michael] Oh yeah. Why, all three,
♪ Come and knock on our door. ♪
(audience laughing)
- [Randy] Gratitude, Gratitude.
- [Michael] Honestly, I
forget there's a TV show.
- [Kelly] All these bright colors.
- [Michael] I'm so cozy with you guys.
I feel like I could,
can I come back again?
- [Kelly] Yes. Same panel.
- [Randy] Hey wait a minute,
should we play poker or something?
- [Michael] Yes.
- [Kelly] I love poker!
- [Randy] Yeah, me too.
- [Kelly] I just bought a poker table
for my ranch in Montana.
- [Randy] Whoa.
- [Kelly] Are you gonna come visit me?
- [Randy] I'll come to Montana.
- [Kelly] It's cold as hell, but it's fun.
- [Randy] Cold as hell but it's fun.
- [Kelly] Yeah. We're all competitive.
- [Randy] Yeah, of course.
- [Kelly] Okay I love it.
- [Randy] But that's what it is.
- [Kelly] Okay next time,
we have to play a game,
that we're all here.
- [Randy] Yes, let's play a game.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- [Michael] I'm in.
- [Kelly] Let's have this
date again guys. Okay okay.